the jurgen experience
the whole thing about like tracking you
on your phone that's normal now would
just normalize getting tracked
everywhere allow location okay
you don't tell me where i am but you
know what the good thing is i'm not
doing nothing bad yeah that's because
i'm not stabbing somebody or i got an
alibi you know this is like the slippery
slope
you know that's what people were worried
about when all that edward snowden [ __ ]
came out that the government can just
track you but now everybody just gives
it up to apps
you know and then they can listen to
everything you say well how many of your
[ __ ]
isn't it been proven has it been proven
that your phone is actually listening to
you yes
right it can we say that or are we crazy
that's tough
i would have to say yeah it probably is
i definitely think they could turn your
microphone on and they can make your
phone listen to you i think that's a
fact i heard a [ __ ] up story and i'll
drop it on you here
i have not a friend
i have an acquaintance that's going to
go to jail because of what they said on
an alexa
oh no
so do not
believe nothing i wouldn't put a [ __ ]
alexa in my house
if you paid me when i walk into people's
houses and i see an alexa i make a
mental note to shut the [ __ ] up
only speak when you know those people
alexa play led zeppelin
alexa i [ __ ] hate you i don't say
nothing to alexa i will never talk to
[ __ ] alexa but they're gonna go to
jail because something happened in their
house like a
a fight
and they actually called the cops
through alexa and oh my god oh
so
you just want to avoid all this [ __ ] if
you have an election in your house oh my
god take it out right now you could play
the music by yourself you dumb [ __ ] oh
my god now you got people listening you
guys listen you got to assume that no
matter what you do they're listening to
you you know i don't give a [ __ ] about
laws or anything or we can't listen
after 30 seconds if you're not talking
about a criminal yeah enterprise it's
listen it's
if you got a cell phone they could tap
into you and they know where you are
it's funny when i go to jiu-jitsu you
have to log in there
they have like a computer like you have
to make a reservation that's what i like
about hollis you can make like
go to zen app and just [ __ ] go i want
to go to
wednesday class and they'll lock a space
in here i think they started because of
kobe but now they don't give a [ __ ]
but when you go there you have to tap in
and i'm so excited to tap in i always go
20 years ago i wouldn't tap into that
[ __ ] because i wouldn't want
nobody to know where i was right now i'm
an old man i don't give a [ __ ] if you
know where i am yeah i came here
yeah my worry about all that stuff
is like who has access to your data
who can track you did you see this come
out a couple nypd had a secret fund for
surveillance tools
documents reveal the police bought
facial recognition software
vans equipped with x-ray machines and
stingray cell site simulators with no
public oversight yikes there's a story
within the last couple weeks i'm trying
to remember exactly what happened but
they tracked whoever
it was and caught them using
license plate camera things and followed
them around the city and like found
their location
uh was when michael k williams died
that's how they tracked where he bought
we have they have on video him buying
the fentanyl yeah jesus christ yeah
so is that good
because you can catch crimes
they didn't stop that didn't you know it
didn't right didn't stop the crime from
happening but they've caught who did it
and i don't know but i don't think that
helps anything really it doesn't right
it gives a lot of power to people that
are working as police officers
you know if you could just like
zoom in on people like that listen in
their cell phone conversations
like
they're just people that's part of the
problem right
but on the other hand it's like
you want them to be able to catch people
when someone's done something [ __ ] up
so where do you draw the line
we have a constitution that they wrote
yeah and it's still [ __ ] illegal it's
like an entrapment i mean like if they
catch someone planting a car bomb
somewhere this is a good for instance
and you can show on a video somehow or
another the people that planted the car
bomb
and that car bomb blows up and a bunch
of people die
shouldn't you be able to find out who
planted that [ __ ] car bomb that's the
slippery part
that's a slippery boat don't tell me
they're not doing that already i think
they don't they go right to a satellite
and see what images they shot on that
block when that area yeah they're
already doing that you have to assume
you have to assume they're doing that
they're already doing that yeah
i think
and what what are the satellite
capabilities like now it must be
incredible
must be amazing
right that's how google earth started
yeah yeah with satellites how crazy is
this
how crazy is this that burglars aren't
even casing joints out anymore
they just go on google earth
they see what cars you park outside
really they case your joint now from
[ __ ] does google earth update
regularly
does it
really i mean it's not like to do 2d
like every day but like some yeah and
there's probably ways like how many
times a month
at least maybe once a month in certain
areas and they have something that is
kind of live because they have caught
i i you know burglars doing it car
thieves doing it i feel like we're in an
episode of black mirror but we just
don't know it yet no you know
it feels like an episode of black mirror
because these guys were getting an order
for a black mercedes
they'd go on the computer
they'd find one they'd go to look i mean
it was all tracked on a [ __ ] computer
never even went by the house before this
was all done right there i watched an
episode of black mirror the other day i
haven't seen that show in a while you
ever watched that on netflix no it's all
about like dystopian future
[ __ ] and the one was about the social
credit system did you see that one oh my
god that was nuts
it's it was all about like what could go
wrong with us you know if we get too uh
wrapped up in uh
grading each other on numbers that one
remember that was a nutty one
it was a real weird one but it's like um
i kind of feel like that's
that's a real possibility for people
that could be a thing we really do one
day have a score everyone give get a
number be
people be obsessed by their score their
social score
like seeing that in that show i was like
yikes
if so you could kind of convince people
to go along with that
yeah that one
you the thing that freaked me out about
it was it was a fun show fun episode but
you could kind of get people to go along
with something like that i don't think
it would be that hard
i think people would give in to some
sort of a score system like that
that's a dangerous thing joey diaz
that's a dangerous thing that's a
dangerous thing because then you're
you're putting so much thought
into like a number
people get obsessed with numbers
they get real weird when it comes to
numbers
if you give people a number like you're
five stars joey you're like oh i'm five
stars yeah but mike's seven stars
we get obsessed i want to be seven stars
what do i have to do
what i have to do
to get the same rating that mike got and
we would want that you meet somebody
after like a year or two he would get
used to it you'd meet somebody
you know
like i can't hang out with this guy he's
a four
you know i mean it's just like he brings
my credit down when i'm around bringing
the three to my house exactly what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you that's what this
happens a lot
[ __ ] bringing the two to my house i'm
telling you that's a that could be
worrisome